der delphi an diesem historischen abend
muss man sagen ein bisschen es von
dieser ganz großen energie
die ist ein bisschen entwichen und jetzt
ist hier also diese erleichterung
gekriegt das vielleicht wird es klingt
ein bisschen hier wie ein rockfestival
ich würde sagen um uns herum stehen
jetzt 45 600 leute wir sind wieder an
den ort gegangen der in den letzten
tagen für viel schlagzeilen gesorgt hat
dort hinten in diesem großen gebäude
die auszählung der stimmzettel
stattgefunden zuvor hatten sich die fans
von joe biden versammelt
um klar zu machen
[Musik]
bottrop also das ist ja
solche fehler werden
ist das also die strom- und ihr seht es
jetzt werden
also große erleichterung große freude
dass dort schon gegangen
[Applaus]
herr harris annahme mir auch immer
wieder hören
mit viel begeisterung
[Applaus]
mehr
von den kosten her
düsseldorf
vielen dank für diese eindrücklichen
schildow ich hoffe du kannst uns noch
hören denn eine sache interessiert
unsere zuschauer die beim letzten mal
schon zugeschaut haben natürlich was ist
aus dem sack donald trump geworden weil
der fox ungeordnet minuten nachdem
unsere seite vorbei war aus dem ring
rausgeflogen ist geplatzt und war kaputt
also ein stück weit auch ein sinnbild
für das was in den letzten 24 stunden
den usa passiert ist
[Musik]
was wenn uns noch eine allerletzte frage
an dich
wie geht das an diesem abend noch weiter
komasaufen oder ziehen die noch durch
die straßen was werden sie jetzt noch
tun und gibt es da auch irgendwo
anhänger von donald trump die sich raus
trauen oder gips die bei dir überhaupt
gar nicht mehr
also ich brauche es neue anziehsachen
ich stinke jetzt dass sekt und
champagner
weil wir hätten früher
ja
mit immer gut
also ein letzter satz ich glaube ich
habe euch verstanden dass trump lager
und ja tatsächlich wenn der christian
einmal die kamera hebt dann seht ihr da
drüben immer doch das jump lager dass
john player steht bis heute da drüben ja
und hält eine letzte wagen fache für
ihren präsidenten kann man sagen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren